hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen zieht
vorstellung rookie und damit sind wir
eigentlich schon direkt nach dem thema
und zwar nein das ist kein halloween
zieht so etwas gibt es nicht glauben
aber es ist ein zieht für die minecraft
1.4.2010 lasst euch davon nicht
beeinflussen dass es einfach fortschritt
den werde ich vielleicht bald auch noch
mal irgendwann vorstellen aber da kommen
wir erst mal zum singleplayer creations
eine neue welt die nennen wir mal stellt
sie vor es eigentlich relativ egal
creative und das ist es sieht blaze of
doom den habe ich unter einem video
gelesen und der wurde die per nachricht
zugesendet habe ich gedacht okay kommen
stellte vor create new world und er ist
eigentlich auch ganz cool
wir sagen ja immer leute nok stellen
nazis mit coolen landschaften vor und
nicht immer so erber draußen village
neuer also sie zum coolen landschaften
zu finden ist sowie die nadel im
heuhaufen wenn er informationen sind
davon gibt es vielleicht 20 30 pro
version die ziemlich cool sind guck mal
was das ist dass hierfür eine anordnung
wieder
es ist das ist naja ok gut wenn ihr
wollt dass ich mehr landschaften
vorstelle dann könnte es mir einfach in
die kommentare schreiben
nur das dauert dann natürlich auch
länger bis eine neue sieht vorstellung
kommt das heißt entweder mehr sieht
vorstellungen dafür so solche coolen
beats oder halt einfach weniger und
dafür dann wenn schon coole landschaften
also das wird einfach mal sagen also das
ponton war direkt hier wenn wir
geradeaus gehen
wir sind einer höhle hier zum
grafikfehler kann man dagegen hauen er
ist der weg als wir haben hier echt
schon eine große hürde die geht da
hinten halt noch weiter das seht ihr da
schon und auf der anderen seite hier
auch hier wieder einen grafik man jedoch
nicht vergeht dir halt auch noch weiter
die hürde
und naja also haben wir direkt eine
dicke höhle mit ärzten wir sind in einem
flatland was ich mit das geilste biom
finde weil man die echten menge bauen
kann
hier haben wir ein
wald der mit ein paar schwein also wenn
ihr da so ein bisschen essen braucht
haben wir direkt einen fetten fetten
dschungel der ist wirklich wirklich fett
das waren auch grade kakaobohnen hab ich
irgendwo gesehen im moment da vielleicht
da waren sie da waren die kakao und der
sinti
naja gut und was eigentlich auch ganz
cool es ist das hier direkt ein dorf das
und zwar eine relativ großes dorf als es
bisher so das größte dorf was ich
gesehen habe eigentlich die haben vier
felder zu wichtige häuser und außerdem
auch eine schmiede aber in der schmiede
das eigentlich nix tolles sondern nur
ein brustpanzer und ein iron also
wirklich nicht so tolles wird das coole
es halt einfach an diesem sieht dass man
wirklich direkt vor einer höhle front
direkt in einem bio zwischen zwei
anderen billionen also die wirklich
direkt in so einer spalte sage ich mal
und zwar weder hinten sumpf hier haben
wir dschungel hierzu den pc dorf und da
als vorderster front direkt in der mitte
neben einer höhle findet eigentlich ein
ganz cooler sich da hinten haben auch
noch eine wüste naja also danke an den
user der mir diese sieht ein gesendet
hat ich habe leider deinen namen nicht
mehr weil ich mir den zieht irgendwann
vor langer zeit mal abgespeichert haben
also vor ein paar tagen war das jetzt na
ja egal
gut wenn ihr das video toll findet oder
ist euch hilfreich war wenn er sieht gut
fanden usw
würde ich mich definitiv über einen
daumen wir freuen uns euch gefallen hat
und dann könnt ihr mir einfach weiteres
in die kommentare schreiben die ich
vorstellen soll und allgemein in den
nächsten in der nächsten zeit werden
wieder mehr videos kommen also nicht nur
täglich ein let's play charts sondern
auch schon person ein paar vorstellungen
wo ich also fällt drauf bin weil ich
große phase ist vorbei ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen mehr frei wegen
allerheiligen und so weiter und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal gysi